[Music]
can I just say what a pleasure it is to
be working with you again I don't think
we need the silencer an item will be
delivered in London are punctured in set
the delivery permit to me you came all
the way from London for us
hands up drop the bag okay kick it over
to me right now kick it over me right
now are you serious okay from the top
the American stole about it they'll give
it to that coward tomorrow you steal it
[Music]
this bag
what's that time does it match my blue
eyes still if Macklin collect the reward
five to six spinning
[Music]
stay where you are game over man it's
over
let's go let's go let's go let's go what
happens to normal people's like me
going for the whole Billy Ray Cyrus
thing that shuts up business in the
front party in the back
wait wearing are you ron jeremy this is
what this is what I wear thank you what
I'm thinking stop [ __ ] we can't go in
there guns a-blazing
it wasn't your pocket it's very small
very small
good morning it's over good morning
I might yeah
[Applause]
[Music]